foreign
right after college my parents took me
back to China to visit extended family
it was a blur of banquet dinners
celebrating my newly minted diploma and
the fancy New York City job I lined up
if you grew up as an immigrant kid
you'll recognize these telltale signs of
a victory tour
near the end of my tour we made a stop
in xinhua my dad's ancestral Village in
Hunan Province
at the top of a Dusty Hill
my dad showed me a crumbling brick
school house where he had learned to
read and write
this Schoolhouse was where he dared to
dream Beyond his means
to become the first person in our family
to get a formal education and go on to
earn a PhD
it was a warm day but I felt a chill I
run up my spine
I was standing in the exact spot
where the trajectory of my lineage began
to diverge from Millions across rural
China
I stared at that decrepit Schoolhouse
and scanned The Horizon
my eyes landing on a white Mercedes-Benz
my cousin had driven in
there is something unsettling about the
juxtaposition of that schoolhouse
and the Mercedes
the Mercedes seemed to represent the
kind of success I have been chasing
but the schoolhouse seemed to represent
the lives of so many people around the
world still
in that moment
my definition of success began to change
I realized I didn't want that Mercedes
I wanted to help tackle large societal
challenges in Economic Development
and ever since that moment on the hill I
have been obsessed with this question of
how to tackle big societal challenges
and make meaningful change
I've served as a consultant to want
Fortune 100 companies
conducted research at the World Bank
worked with non-profits across Africa
and founder the Y combinator backed
company
today
I want to share what I've learned on how
to make meaningful change
tackle big problems
use startups and partner with government
first
use startups to tackle big problems
why use startups you may ask
because startups are designed for Speed
to test new ideas quickly adapt to
changes and prototype Solutions
this iterative approach is extremely
powerful when directed towards a North
star
here in Silicon Valley we often hear the
Mantra test fast and break things
I've lived and breathed this ethos when
my startup went through y combinator
I co-founded high of Health the first
digital health insurance company in the
Philippines
we provide affordable quality Health
Care to small medium businesses whose
employees and loved ones currently are
uninsured
fixing the broken Health Care system is
the crumbling schoolhouse
I relish the feeling of being Scrappy
and testing fast we will launch little
experiments to test our value
proposition doing things that definitely
didn't scale
for instance to lock in our first
customer we drove across Manila in a
thunderstorm to do a live demo
what kind of recommend
testing fast is still my favorite part
of Entrepreneurship
enables me to think creatively to solve
a problem using whatever resources I
have in my disposal
it's Innovation out of necessity to
solve a problem that really matters
as I got deeper and deeper into the test
fast break things world I started to
wonder
is breaking things really a good
guideline
I see two flaws with this approach
the first issue with test fast break
things is the potential of breaking
things that shouldn't be broken
in healthcare this could literally be a
matter of life or death
Maverick disregard for rules meant to
safeguard well-being
can also be detrimental for business
the second more Insidious issue with
test fast and break things
is it may limit entrepreneurs to focus
in on niches where the cost of breaking
things
is trivial
startups that focus on problem spaces
where the cost of breaking things
doesn't matter may be able to profit
from Arbitrage
but it limits their potential for
Meaningful change
instead of building something custom fit
for the sidelines it's better to step
onto the field to meet the challenge
head on
instead of test fast and break things we
should test fast and fix things
starves can be effective in tackling big
problems
and starves are uniquely positioned to
do so because of the ability to test
fast
my second learning for tackling big
problems is to partner with government
I have seen firsthand what is possible
when entrepreneurs and policy makers
view each other as collaborators instead
of enemies
flashback to 2021 I'm in my Cambridge
apartment fiercely clicking refresh
no I'm not waiting for the latest
Netflix release
I was waiting for something far juicier
the publication of a new regulation on
the Philippine insurance commission
website
juicy right
after months of discussion with the
government we had co-developed a new
regulatory sandbox framework
this sandbox enabled us to test new
Innovations in healthcare financing for
the 100 million underinsured population
in the Philippines
a regulatory sandbox is a way for
government to allow private sector to
test new Innovations within the
safeguards of a controlled environment
it started in the UK and it's spread
globally to places like Singapore India
and Kenya
without the sandbox we would not have
been able to fundamentally design a new
patient experience
on the other hand the consequences of
not partnering with government can be
detrimental
for instance Uber poured in millions but
failed to capture the Asian market
because it tried to bulldoze through
regulation while its competitor grab
proactively engaged government in each
step along the way and that's flourish
to become the largest super app across
Southeast Asia
what I've learned from partnering with
government is that it got us to the
place faster it made us more ambitious
than doing it by ourselves
starves can be effective in tackling big
problems in doing so with government is
more efficient
government has the scale advantages that
a startup can only dream of but not the
organizational model to test quickly
startups can innovate quickly
but we don't have the scale that's
needed necessarily
now back to tackling big problems
there is no Silver Bullet
to address Universal and societal
challenges like Health Care
inequality
or climate change
entrepreneurship may not be for everyone
and starves exist within an ecosystem of
other important stakeholders
there are also regulatory environments
that are truly visiting
like the U.S Healthcare System for
instance
where progress may take a bit more time
but my experience in the Philippines has
taught me that success is possible
potentially at a large scale
it first requires finding a problem
that's worth solving
starting a company takes a lot of effort
and if you're going to spend that much
time on something why not make it
worthwhile by directing it to problems
of consequence
and I will bet problems of consequence
will require partnering with government
in one way or another
I hope you'll each reflect on what is
your version of our crumbling
Schoolhouse and let it be the north star
that guides you
you may you never know where you may go
so don't aim for the shiny Mercedes fix
the crumbling Schoolhouse do it with a
startup and partner with government
let's test fast and fix things
foreign